craig danic enchaîne les tours de
circuit a dit long il se prépare pour le
championnat du monde junior en suède au
mois de septembre prochain
craig n'a pas froid aux yeux il fera
tout pour faire une performance
c'est un honneur de pouvoir participer
aux championnats du monde pour
représenter la martinique là c'est
pratiquement que des pros qui roule donc
ça me permettre de pouvoir moi commencer
à rouler avec des pros pratiquement et
de pouvoir me lever à leur niveau et
même peut-être les dépasser du haut de
ses 14 ans craig a été sacré le 22
juillet dernier champion de france
junior de karting pendant la course il a
fait preuve d'une maîtrise
extraordinaire mais surtout et c'est son
point fort
craig est motivé et il sait s'adapter à
toutes les circonstances
depuis que j'ai commencé je me suis
senti bien et j'ai continué la semaine
au plus haut niveau
bah ça motive les champions de france
juniors j'avais participé au championnat
du monde en suède et on a fait un test
en le mois dernier pour le championnat
d'europe et c'est la dernière manche
greg n'a pas choisi ce sport par hasard
comme obélix il est tombé dedans depuis
tout petit 6 par an sont tous les du
d'anciens champions de martinique de la
discipline il avait trois ans et demi
que il a conduit son premier kart
aujourd'hui l'adolescent rentre en
troisième les déplacements hors de la
martinique sont nombreux et cela demande
aux parents d'y sacrifices et toute une
organisation notamment pour le collège
au niveau du
de la scolarité on s'arrange donc avec
l'établissement dont il est à la m ça se
passe très bien donc en fait on échange
beaucoup dix ans le programme comment on
va s'organiser puis avec certains
profession on arrive à échanger par
mille donc ça permet de concilier les
deux et lui de toute façon il est bien
conscient que dès qu'il nous retournons
martinique le lendemain les dents devant
dans sa classe et il reprend son le fil
de la vie la chance d'avoir un enfant on
le suit jusqu'au bout les résultats sont
là maintenant tous les congés pas ça les
vacances on a la chance d'être des
passionnés donc on vit ça jusqu'au bout
l'année prochaine craig rentrera dans la
cour des grands avec des cartes à
vitesse à force de travail et de
persévérance
le jeune homme peut toucher les étoiles